[Music]  the Duggar family is expanding yet again  we are expecting Jill Duggar Dillard and  her husband Eric announced Tuesday  morning they are expecting baby number  two  Ezreal is gonna be a great big brother  he already loves just other little  babies and the only thing I think you'll  have to work on is just learning that  babies that are smaller than you have to  be more gentle with Israel turned 1 in  April earlier this month ET learned of  another expansion of the Duggar family  parents Jim Bob and Michelle Duggar were  granted permanent custody of their  eight-year-old nephew at Tyler Dwayne  Hutchins their attorney said his mother  was quote presently unable to meet  Tyler's health safety and other needs  Tyler's mother 23 year old Rachel signed  off on the guardianship in addition to  agreeing to supervised visits with her  son